cyberpunk 2077 happy wednesday reject
nation
i always outdate the videos by saying
things like that at the top we're gonna
watch two cyberpunk videos today we're
gonna watch the official gameplay
trailer the official
johnny silverhand trailer who i believe
is keanu reeves character
hence the matrix was a documentary shirt
we'll start with the counter reese one
where'd you even come from how i don't
even talking
gotta get out of here i understand and
i'll kill anyone who gets it by the way
you are a dream those are memories
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
just for fun
you already tried to take over your body
you know
just for a little while
whoa like billy butcher
damn that future ted is a badass we'll
talk about it a little bit after the
next trailer but
damn that was crazy diana was crazy yeah
let's move on to the gameplay we'll talk
a little bit about that one
[Music]
we dedicate ourselves to telling
immersive stories
yet with every new project we set out to
make our games bigger
more complex deeply engaging
cyberpunk 2077 marries
don't feel like a city doesn't give you
a choice you have to burn alive
but it never existed at all the year is
2077.
an economic crisis culminating in
nuclear conflict has left america in
pieces
with most of the continent degenerating
into lawless war zones
people from all over have converged on
the already overcrowded
night city one of the world's last great
megalopolises
[Music]
what
[Music]
religious cultists politicians and all
manner of criminals
strive to outplay one another ordinary
people
get caught in the crossfire looking for
justice in night city
i seek revenge much more feasible
in this world consumed by never-ending
conflict
sometimes only an outsider will get the
job done
elizabeth tells me you have answers for
us i'm all ears
and that's you an urban mercenary a
cyber-enhanced gun for hire
you seem to understand each other take
this
as a mercenary you swear no allegiance
you've chosen the outlaw life
and trust that your abilities will carry
you up night city's ruthless
underground social networks
to thrive as a merc you need the right
combination of gear
skills and reputation wow
i hope he wasn't overselling with the
money you earn
you can turn yourself into a living
weapon buying guns and enhancements
you gain the experience you need to
upgrade abilities and acquire perks
combine the right skills and gear to
create a gunslinger within human
reflexes
a stealthy network
minority reporters
the only way to prevent the biochip from
failing is to slaughtered into your head
oh no soul of johnny silverhand
oh no that's how it all ties in okay
that's crazy whoa
that is crazy aims to bring down the
mega corp that made the chip
do whatever it takes to stop defeat
what is in your head can shift the
balance of power in night city
[Music]
yahoo
the choices you make will shape your
story and determine how events
unfold
but not everything in night city is a
matter of life and death
sometimes it's about style choosing your
look
you're right you're past time who's at
your side
choosing how you spend your dirty money
oh lady
that that looks like the coolest thing
ever all right john take it away that
looks freaking awesome i mean that looks
like the perfect combination of video
game fantasy meets like every sci-fi
movie you've ever wanted to live inside
i mean you pointed out
minority report there's obviously like
blade runner stuff there were moments i
was flashing in the desert to like
terminate or where you're blowing up
endoskeletons and whatnot and yeah i
mean
as the promise of an action adventure
game with also this
huge open world capability customization
like
you can get your sims kick your grand
theft auto kick and yeah just all that
fantasy sci-fi action you want and it's
awesome to know that keanu reeves isn't
just like an easter egg or a fun little
bit character he's actually like a part
of the driving force of
the game so that's a neat thing to have
revealed to us keanu reeves feels like
so many of all of his characters just
melded into one you got some johnnyman
monica in here
you got some obviously a little bit of
neo just because of cyberpunk world
right
john wick you got ted from
he's a musician as well um
yeah so like having this hybrid of all
him but he's also the super aggressive
keanu reeves like when he's yelling at
those two women in knock knock
he's in that version of kyoto he's very
aggressive and i'm excited for his
character because i feel like he can be
really fun but also perhaps a little bit
scary at times or a little bit
intimidating i mean there's no better
time for
a dystopian game to participate in we
got the last of us too earlier this year
now we're getting cyberpunk 2077
and two different sides of a dystopian
future
one looks a little bit more appealing
than the other to live in you know
because you at least get all this cool
technology
to immerse yourself in but this also
dealing with environmental and economic
conditions it feels very
relevant to the time right now i mean
the world of a cyberpunk
is not exactly brand new like this looks
like a melding of a whole bunch of
movies and anime and everything
in terms of relevancy it really dawned
on me watching this one
this looks like it's pretty relevant and
also the other thing i'll give it to is
it looks
very intense looks grippingly like i
i feel like there's going to be some
high-stakes missions where i'm just
going to be
not only having fun but on the edge of
my seat from pulse pounding
story development weirdly that hasn't
been
the thing i've associated with cyberpunk
and this time it gave me that where
i thought the trailer did a great job
setting up the world setting up the
character the main character you'll be
playing as
even though it's open world it'd be the
main character to be playing as but also
all the odds and
everything that are stacked against you
in this game and how bonkers it'll be
you know so i think that uh i think this
is going to be a
a game a game where we will be demanding
a sequel right when it comes out
2078 yeah let's get it going guys and i
just think it would be
so funny that if this game comes out and
it's just crap
that it comes out everyone hates it and
they're like
damn what a disappointment this game was
a short storyline there's glitches
everywhere the world doesn't have
graphics are nowhere near as good as we
thought they would be
it's boring i just think it's so funny
if that's what happens when it comes out
seriously because like you get so many
options
with this story in the open world and
the amount of different like the
the emotional investment i imagine you
can just immerse yourself with for this
game for
months on end it's like outlaw sims in
the future
it would be funny all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below cyberpunk
2077 hit that like button if you enjoyed
our video
subscribe last but not least
speaking of pandemics pandemic jones pj
what's going on dude pj
i know these days you have a good amount
of time on your hands for the evening to
enjoy yourself so i hope you get a time
to be all pandemic jones-like by
indulging yourself
in something that is a more enjoyable
not really a pandemic
but probably the resulting effect of
something
like you know where it goes around
spread some love pandemic style
or you know encouragement creativity and
you know with your name being
jones it just has me think of this
whenever i get to message you
i can't stand with my left hand but it's
not unusual to be
loved by anyone that's you buddy
i love loving you and i love being loved
by you
and i work more off of that feeling than
i do for the feeling given to you
what's new pussycat whoa
[Music]
you